♪ ♪
>> Laura: MY NEXT GUEST HAS
SPARKED A NATIONAL DEBATE ON THE
CONVENTIONAL WISDOM ABOUT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS AND POLITICS.
CANDACE OWENS HAS URGED BLACK
VOTERS TO THINK INDEPENDENTLY
FOR THEMSELVES AND TO QUESTION
LIBERAL ORTHODOXY.
SHE HAS BEEN MERCILESSLY
ATTACKED ONLINE, BUT COMING TO
HER DEFENSE, INTERESTINGLY, HAS
BEEN HIP-HOP STAR KANYE WEST.
HE TWEETED ON SATURDAY "I LOVE
THE WAY CANDACE OWENS THINKS."
IS HE PLUNKING US?
WHAT'S GOING ON QUESTION BECAUSE
WE SHARE WITH YOU LAST NIGHT, A
HIP-HOP RADIO HOST CLAIMS WEST
TOLD HIM THAT HE LOVES
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HE LIKES
OWENS BECAUSE SHE IS CHALLENGING
CONVENTIONAL BLACK THOUGHT.
JOINING ME NOW GEORGE RESPOND TO
THE CONTROVERSY IS CANDACE ONCE
HERSELF.
HEY, HOW ARE YOU?
>> I'M DOING GREAT.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Laura: YOU GO TO A COLLEGE
CAMPUS AND START TALKING ABOUT
THINK FOR YOURSELF AND BE YOUR
OWN PERSON.
GOSH, THAT'S KIND OF A "ME TOO"
THING.
STAND UP FOR YOURSELF.
DON'T BE A VICTIM.
I WAS LISTENING.
I DIDN'T SEE WHO IT WAS.
I THOUGHT IT SAY "ME TOO" THING.
THEN I THOUGHT ALL, IT'S CANDACE
OWENS.
WHY IS THIS SO CONTROVERSIAL?
WERE YOU SURPRISED THAT THIS
BECAME SUCH A BIG DEAL.
OBVIOUSLY KANYE WEIGHS IN BUT
WERE YOU SURPRISED QUESTION
MEXICO ACTUALLY WASN'T SURPRISED
AT ALL.
THIS IS WHAT I'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT ACROSS COLLEGE CAMPUSES
WITH TURNING POINT USA.
THERE IS A LIBERAL
INDOCTRINATION, THEY THINK THEY
HAVE A MONOPOLY NOT JUST ON OUR
STUDENTS PUSH WAS WHAT WE DO A
TURNING POINT USA BUT ALSO ON
THE ENTIRE BLACK RACE IN
AMERICA.
THEY CANNOT FATHOM THAT WE MIGHT
HAVE DIFFERENT IDEAS.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND BECAUSE
THEY HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY CREATED
A MENTAL PRISON FOR ALL OF US.
THE SECOND SOMEBODY RUNS OFF
WHAT I REFER TO OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PLANTATION, THEY SEND
THE DOGS OUT.
>> Laura: INTERESTING MOMENT
ON THE RADIO SHOW, AN
INTERESTING HOST.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT KANYE WEST
AND HE WAS SAYING KANYE IS NOT
THINKING A DEPENDENTLY BECAUSE
HE LIVES IN A BUBBLE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> KANYE IS TALKING ABOUT THINGS
THAT DON'T AFFECT THEM.
>> LET'S BE HONEST.
NONE OF THESE THINGS AFFECT HIM.
HE LIVES IN A BUBBLE WHERE IT'S
UNDERSTAND.
ALL HE IS SURROUNDED BY IS THE
KARDASHIANS AND A BUNCH OF YES
MEN AND IN THE FASHION WORLD.
HE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE STREETS, WHAT'S
HAPPENING WHEN IT COMES TO
PROTESTS.
NONE OF THAT.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND.
AS IF THERE AREN'T
MULTIMILLIONAIRE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, LATINOS, AND
OTHERS LIVING IN BELLER, BRENT,
MALIBU.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T LIVE ON THE
STREETS, THEN YOU CAN'T COMMENT
ON ANYTHING?
ODD BRINGING IN THE KARDASHIANS.
WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH THAT
COMMENT QUESTION MEXICO WASN'T A
VERY SMART COMMENT.
A SALACIOUS ARGUMENT THAT COULD
BE ATTACKED A THOUSAND DIFFERENT
WAYS.
TO SUGGEST THAT BECAUSE SOMEBODY
IS MONEY THEY CAN'T THINK OR
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY KNOWLEDGE OR
FACTS OR DATA MAKES ENTIRELY NO
SENSE.
IN FACT, YOU COULD ARGUE THAT
THEY MAY HAVE MORE ACCESS TO
THINGS.
AFTER THAT JUST INCREDIBLY LOW
I.Q. WAS WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, THESE
RADIO HOSTS ARE NOT THE GREAT
PHILOSOPHERS OF OUR TIME.
THEY DO THEY DO.
THEY GET ON THERE AND THEY TRY
TO THROW UP THE CONTROVERSY,
TALK ABOUT THE STORY OF THE DAY.
>> Laura: WELL, I AM A RADIO
HOST AND I TALK ABOUT THE
SUBJECTS OF THE DAY BUT I TRY TO
DO IT WITH SOME DEGREE OF
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPENSE.
CANDACE, WHERE YOU GOING NEXT
QUESTION MEXICO I'M GOING TO
KEEP DOING WHAT I'M DOING.
I AM GOING TO KEEP PUNCHING BAG.
I HAVE ZERO FEAR.
I KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO BE THE
BLOWBACK.
I KNOW YOU RECENTLY HAS MIXED
GREENS WITH THIS.
YOU UNDERSTAND MOB MENTALITY.
THE RESULT IS USUALLY HAS
ADVERSE RESULTS.
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE SEEN WITH YOUR
SHOW.
WE ARE GOING TO SEE THE SAME
THING IN THE BLACK UNITY.
CREATE CONFLICT AND AT THE END
THE DAY IT ENDS UP WAKING UP
MORE PEOPLE.